at midnight last night
failed former president twice impeached
and once arrested Donald Trump
seemed to have a textual panic attack on
Troth Central over what appears to be at
this time an inevitable forthcoming
indictment and arrest federally
federally these are the all capital
letters posts of a panicked madman who
is scared and may be realizing that his
time is running out Trump posting at
midnight last night quote shocking one
of the top prosecutors at the department
of Injustice was reportedly so obsessed
with getting Trump that he tried to
bribe and intimidate a lawyer
representing someone being targeted and
harassed who falsely accuse and
fabricate a story about President Donald
J Trump a crime that doesn't exist this
criminal and salacious act from within
the doj has brought criminal and
salacious I'm sorry has brought shame
and embarrassment to this once great and
respected institution I struggle so
badly to read these Trump rants because
of this there is now extreme turmoil
inside the doj unclear that that's true
Trump continuing on post two and
labeling it page two a top over zealous
and dishonest doj prosecutor offered a
witness's lawyer an important judgeship
in the Biden Administration if his
client flips on President Trump
who has done nothing wrong the highly
respected lawyer was incensed and
disgusted at the corrupt and illegal
offer the fake case against me must be
immediately dropped and the Inspector
General should launch an investigation
into this and the many other all too
obvious wrongdoings and crimes taking
place at the doj and FBI it's very
difficult to find anything that is true
here we do not have any evidence of
alleged crimes committed by the doj and
FBI we have no evidence at this time
that there is overzealous prosecution of
Donald Trump in fact the truth is the
opposite the concern has been and the
Rumblings have pointed to even with
evidence against Trump of trump
criminality
it doesn't seem clear that there's a
willingness by the Department of Justice
to actually indict a former president we
now are starting to believe that that's
not true and that the doj is going to go
forward and indict Trump but there is
essentially nothing real here but you
have to understand that this is the
court of public opinion and the Maga the
magats or the magedonians or whatever
they're being called at this point in
time
they accept this stuff like it's being
spoon fed to them they they uncritically
accept it period end of story and so
much of this could be working to
activate voters either for the
Republican primary or the eventual
general election in November of 24 there
are all sorts of other reasons why Trump
would be doing this including that the
guy is just panicking and scared because
he's already been indicted and arrested
once and it could happen three more
times we're going to follow it all very
closely by the time this show is out we
may already know more or we may not
until tomorrow or maybe next week the
weather is about to start warming up and
that often means sweating and chafing
and sticking sheath is the men's
underwear that once and for all puts an
end to all of that nonsense our sponsor
sheath underwear has designed unique
boxer briefs with an ergonomic
compartment built to keep everything
separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great experience with sheath underwear I
know you will too head on over to
sheathunderwear.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for 20 off the link is down
below